today we are gonna be watching
BuzzFeed's cutest all this videos yeah
we will this isn't let's crack let's
crack open let's crack it up let's crack
crack it off kittens meet puppies for
the first time from BuzzFeed Australia
oh this is gonna ruin man this is first
time meeting and I just want them to be
friends shut the [ __ ] up shut them
thought they all look like my cat Peter
oh my god there's so many puppies and so
little kittens oh my god I forgot how
fun kittens are Oh drink all your little
milks together oh you're just what they
give a milk
Australia this is epic music oh this is
so pure I had no idea oh you put his
hand on the kitten to be in this moment
us of being Philip I'm so happy
it makes sense to me why that has 18
million views yes watch that and like
keep rewatching and realizing remember
when the internet was like 50% just cat
and dog videos there was no scandals
their words no drama was so pure and
then people decided to get a bunch of
opinions okay next one Oh girls get
surprised with puppies and pretty sure
I've seen this one and I'm pretty sure I
love this is gold two of my favorite
things getting drunk and playing with
puppies I honestly think this is why
I'll never like Zach Kornfeld because he
didn't put me in this video I love dogs
they're like the best thing in the world
I love puppies we need to do more happy
[Laughter]
they want to be each other so pure
clearly you could have two people at the
table so I'm like wondering why yeah you
didn't reach out you know like look at
this dog and look at this no they
adoptable remember you guys just kept
bringing dogs in here that was so crazy
so fun probably the cutest video I think
we've done just like an overload of like
happiness and warmth we did get to meet
those puppies and it was a great day
they were filming yeah I do remember the
time when there was like almost every
other week there
something going on with puppies yeah
there's so many cute videos ah I don't
decieve 30 minute puppy massage it's
just a puppy getting a full massage
isn't this one singular puppy he wants
to get away he was trying to get away in
the beginning which is also how I feel
during massage he's sleeping he needed
to just calm down
Oh his little back leg it's I just love
that he's like fully limp getting a
stretch I was stretching with hmm
everything's so new to him who wouldn't
be stressed out his name's apricot how
do you pronounce it apricot apricot haha
this is all we've done on one camera if
they had done it today I think they
probably wouldn't use to and cut between
and just use the moments or the puppies
like really relaxed or like something to
make it more entertaining for audience
but this is 30 straight minutes of one
shot tortoises drag tiny bit towards
this our cue that was a question
oh oh there's something very adorable
about a thing that eats without hands
yes but not what humans do it no they
didn't even give him any serum that's
what I'm saying
right pancakes our pancakes good for
tortoises diets I don't know a lot the
things that are bad for your little
mouth is not gonna fit around that oh
thank you yeah if we made this today
there'd be a lot more like text and
flying around but I appreciate this is
very minimal it's just beautiful it is
he's a little baby guy he's not gonna
nap about it I wish I knew minding
emissive it's cute but it somehow feels
education yeah I've never been this
close to a tortoise maintain layer when
I see something so cute I really do to
sort of squeeze your control it explodes
I think you videos are evergreen I agree
you can't really tell that they're old
videos is like cuteness like it doesn't
really change over time that could have
been made yesterday would have been like
yes I'm sure like a few years from now
ASMR videos people are gonna look back
on that and be like remember when
everyone was whispering in the
microphones in 2018 like that's so
bizarre but it's so calming they're just
like
[Music]
not everyone is meant for greatness some
people are supposed about it so we've
done here
[Music]